they will face uh right header zac eflin
comes in with a four and six record an
era of 3.88
he's making his 18th start of the season
now this is game two so the marlins bats
are awake they've had batting practice
heck they've had a full game
ground ball and it's bobbled by
gregorius can't make the play
well just as jazz had something of a
crucial error
in
the first game led to some more runs
gregorius starts out with an error at
short in game two
first 25 pitches in a ball game effluent
has given up eight home runs
and a 361 batting average against ethan
brings home a 2-1 pitch and marte hits
one high in the year deep center field
it sends williams back and that is into
the philly's bullpen
two-run home run for starling marte
now that has got to feel good for
starling marte a big big swing
here in the first inning of game two
and after the way game one went nice to
see the marlins get out to a quick start
here in the nightcap for the marlins it
is ross dentweiler this will be his
fourth start of the season we've seen
him in spots like this before not
necessarily the double headers so to
speak but in these sort of opening roles
the one-two to glorious is swinging a
foul tip into the catcher's mitt leone
hangs on for the strikeout to get that
water through a scoreless first inning
no runs a hit a walk two left couple of
k's needing for detweiler you look at
what jordan has done and what his stuff
his stuff up here plays that's a diving
play over there at third by joe panic
that one ticketed for the corner
and able to make the sliding diving
tight play up the line
three for six in limited at bats 1-2
and holloway gets the strikeout two-way
nice job by jordan doubling up
saw the awkward swing from verling on
the second strike he was completely
fooled by the breaking ball but you
don't want to make a mistake here and
give him a good breaking ball to hit
as martin's against effluent and he
hammers one again this one out to left
center field that's going to stay in the
ballpark but it's going to be down for a
base hit williams cuts it digging for
second marta the throw won't be in time
so starling martay who had been ice cold
had a single his last time up in game
one he's now homer and doubled his first
two times up here in game two
maybe that hit got him going but
that's what i was even talking about
last game remember i said this is a guy
who even when he doesn't hit the ball
out of the ballpark he can create
doubles
2-2 martay dances off the second that's
sharply hitting its pass gd into left
field martay is going to get the green
light around third here comes throw
won't be anywhere near in time marte
scores in rbi for
jesus aguilar and a three-nothing lead
for the marlins
now this a rocket off the bat of aguilar
effluent made a mistake out over the
play just a little bit more continued to
pound him the same way but missed all of
no strikes on miggy and rojas toward
left center field that's going to get
down
mccutcheon cuts it off panic will
stop at third got a late stop sign from
trey hillman
who i think just wanted panic to have a
head of steam just in case there was a
bobble and that's second and third
that's exactly right trey did everything
right as he made his way towards home
play trying to get as much
of a read on the ball back in as he
possibly could remember there's two outs
in the inning this ball well struck big
day for rojas his fourth hit of the day
that left center field gat mccutchen
cuts it off before it gets to the wall
saving the phillies a run
that's what trey hillman was watching
where where was gregorius
sharply diving stop on one hot by reese
hoskins underhand to first
that was outstanding
3-1 on the put out
put a star
circle it you will not see a better play
by a first baseman as he picked that
line drive on a one hot and flipped it
over to epplin for the final out
that's how you help out your pitcher and
that will get the phillies out of the
inning without any more damage who came
into tonight's action with what was it
four for eight against effluent in his
career with three doubles what's he got
tonight a homer and a double and another
hit for marty this one is going to get
toward the gap cut it off by williams in
center but jazz is going to score no
throw
and starling marty having himself quite
the night tonight
another rbi another double
another run for the marlins it's 4-0
yeah he has been the biggest part of
this offense here in game two another
great swing to nearly the same part of
center field as his last double in the
third inning
and the marlins have a four-nothing lead
and a chance for a little bit more
here's aguilar the right-hander from the
stretch the kick in the 0-2 and aguilar
drives with a long way deep to left
field and into the night a three-run
homer jesus aguilar's three for three
he's knocked in four and the marlins
have busted it open it's seven nothing
in the fourth
[Applause]
zeus aguilar
first off
we just talked about how he likes that
fastball up
and where was that fastball glenn that
was a fastball up
this season or since the start of last
season he's in 355 on elevated fastballs
and he had home eight home runs on
fastballs elevated the season jordan
holloway fastball as you watch how
quickly it gets on hitters
even visually it seems to be a bit more
than even the 95 or 96 it shows on the
gun there's another look at it
another strikeout for holloway making
four out of the pen jordan kind of hangs
out in first and second gear right kind
of then all of a sudden boom he just
kind of gets on you right and with the
stuff that he has on those good days i
mean there he's going to be
in like the untouchable range
he'll throw to first to complete the
strikeout and he's got five out of the
bullpen
but you got to imagine that he's just
filling up the confidence bucket right
now oh there's no doubt he profiles well
he's a big strong kid he's got great
stuff
the padres are up 18-4 on the nationals
jazz
gets the one and how is that not a
double play well it will be when it's
all said and done
i thought jankowski ran out of the
baseline
if he did or he didn't it doesn't matter
they get the out at second nonetheless
and it's a marlins win
seven to nothing the final score yeah
rather convincing fashion they get it
done a couple of outstanding offensive
performances